best protocol for Candida and yeast overgrowth.
Feeling through all these episodes, we're going to get questions like this and these are
very honest questions.
What's the best protocol?
The truth is, is that there isn't – I don't know how to say this really nicely, but
I know we are so conditioned through the medical system that here's my – I've gotten
to this diagnosis, however I've gotten to this diagnosis, give me the medication to
a go away.
That's not really in my mind the proper way to take care of somebody.
The proper way to take care of somebody is, okay, maybe we have this diagnosis but let's
ask a question, why?
Why is it there?
Is it because you have a deficiency of this Candida supplement?
That's why you have Candida, though that might really help.
We're not going to ultimately help the patient unless we dig to why.
Is there an imbalance in the microbiota because of what?
Let's figure that out.
If we can figure that out and treat that, maybe we don't even have to seek that other
supplement, right, or that drug or whatever, so it's not – I wish I could – why are
you going to be mad at me?
I ask you the questions of just giving me a supplement, they're just giving me a medication
or giving me a solution, that's not the right way to take care of somebody in my book.
Sure, there's a ton of – every supplement company that we use has a Candida protocol.
But then are we being just like the practice of medicine, so different than having a
Birk manual that a medical doctor follows and he or she is just a technician, and they
come to this diagnosis because we did this lab and here's the diagnosis, here's the drug
that we give by come back in three months and we'll see how you're doing and see if we've
altered the lab value.
Maybe you will, but did you help the person in any real way, did you really correct the
reason why?
This is – we could do the same thing in natural realms too, I don't like doing that.
I don't really have a good answer for that, I apologize, my answer would be we need to dig
it to dig deeper to figure out the reasons why.